let me test you guys okay okay because
i always had trouble with the
libertarians in the administration
how do you guys feel about tariffs on
china
and uh well give me a little bit more
detail like uh so so okay so in the in
trump time book there's a great scene
where
i do go mono himano with chris wallace
on his sunday show oh right yeah and
it's like we're in each other's face and
he goes
what's the problem with china i go and
it just pops out of my head because it's
sunday right it's biblical i go to seven
deadly sins right and so i go okay so
here's the problem it's it's even get
all seven it's always it's always a
chore okay
okay you start with the intellectual
property theft to the tune of half a
trillion dollars a year you got forced
technology transfer
which is if you want to go and do
business in china
you got to hand over your technology
right totally unfair trade you've got
the the constant cyber hacking both of
personal individuals for their credit
card whatever but also businesses right
stealing their ip another form you've
got what's called dumping which is
sending
product below cost into markets as a way
of pushing the domestic producers out
and and grabbing hold of those markets
you have china's state-owned enterprises
i'm up to five now right so these are
the these are the national champions
they send out with the with the full
power of the state to go out and do
battle and why why it's china building
our subway systems instead of american
companies um currency manipulation which
is like china lowers the value of their
currency which makes their exports here
cheaper and are our exports to them
more expensive so our trade deficit goes
up and then there's the seven
uh is the killing of americans
with deadly fentanyl and that's both a
health crisis
as well as an economic thing because a
lot of the people who die from fentanyl
are
working age
manufacturing blue-collar workers okay
so
um the the libertarian the traditional
libertarian view is that well if china
wants to sell us cheap goods we should
just
benefit from them
and what i'm going is no no no no it's
like
that's a form of economic aggression if
you take it as like a snapshot and you
go into walmart and stuff cheap that's
cool okay that's what but if you play it
like as a movie over time and all your
jobs go offshore
and your wages are driven down and
people go to the unemployment line and
and workers wind up committing suicide
because they don't have jobs that's a
serious thing so i get back and
like in the in trump time book i
identify this this set of what i call
the wall street transactionalists like
mnuchin at treasury kudlow with the
national economic council mulvaney big
libertarian it's like i try to do like
buy american policies or china tariffs
and these guys freak out so i i'll throw
it back to you guys
libertarian do you do
tariffs on china to protect yourself
well there's two different libertarians
now you've got the mises caucus and
you've got the establishment you know
old-school type libertarians and they
disagree on a lot of things yeah so i
think the mises guys are like pro
borders right yeah very much so yeah
yeah so they're probably going to say we
have to protect american workers in
america and then i think their view is
more like within the area that we can
protect we have libertarian values and
views on how things are run yeah but we
recognize you know outside of the
borders so i i i don't know if that's
exactly their view but i would say my
view is is similar to that like i don't
want china ripping off american workers
using
economic coercion and warfare to try and
destroy this country so
everything within the borders i believe
in you know very libertarian individual
liberties individual rights civil rights
etc and then when it comes to
international trade and stuff we must
protect the people in our you know
here's an interesting stat for you folks
our trade deficit with china is roughly
equivalent to the people's liberation
army defense budget
so
and and by the way uh it's tuesday and
friday is not just friday it is black
friday and that's when everybody's going
to be going to the big box baby
walmart target whatever and a lot of
that stuff they're going to buy
when they pick up that made in china
stuff is actually going to be uh you
plow
plows into uh swords pile shares into
swords because
that stuff is that money or trade death
as it goes to fund all other weapons and
what drives me nuts is is you ask at the
beginning who i am it's like the way i
met donald trump i talk about the
interrupt time book because there was
some confusion there i wrote a trilogy
of china books right
2006 the coming china wars
2011 the death by china book and film
and then those were economic base and
then 2015 crouching tiger uh which was
the rise of the chinese military so like
in 2015 i write this book and say yeah
china's developing these hypersonic
missiles that can kill us with nuclear
weapons right okay so that's like six
years ago and so china just a couple of
weeks ago they fly a hypersonic
playing around in low orbit which is
capable of bristling with weapons and
everybody's go wow wow that's surprising
oh my gosh
no it's not it's like in 2006
i predicted uh in the coming china wars
that china would create a global
pandemic because of the way they handled
the viruses and it was based on my
research of how sarge one came about my
point
here is that china is an existential
threat you got you had joe biden say
it's no no it's just simply a competitor
and part of what i've been trying to do
and what president trump was absolutely
transformative about
was to raise people's awareness as they
used to say in the 60s about the the
threat
of communist china the chinese communist
party coming after us and they're coming
after us and
there he is so what what
what do tariffs do how will that help so
the way
tariffs work um
if you if you if you if
if you have a country like china
that is dumping product in or stealing
areas whatever the tariffs first and
foremost offset the advantage that
they've gotten from the unfair trade so
that's your first best right but what we
were also trying to do with china
was to get them to the bargaining table
so in some sense the tariffs were a
penalty for things like intellectual
property theft or currency manipulation
so it was fascinating the the first
chapter of the book i call it the red
wedding chapter uh in homage to game of
thrones but we're sitting we're sitting
there in the east swing and the
president's about to sign this this
skinny trade deal where we're supposed
to deal with this economic uh
aggression
and um
it's like i'm fighting the wall street
transactionalists because all they were
concerned is if china buy some more
soybeans or whatever they weren't
focused on the core problem but we had
this strategy
it was called dragging in a pot like
think about this it's like we knew that
there was be resistance to tariffs
initially among a certain segment of the
public but to get people to accept them
what we did what pre this was brilliant
president trump he got china to enter
into negotiations every time china did
something in those negotiations which
was unfair we'd raise the tariffs and
that allowed us over time to steadily
increase the tariffs to over 3 billion
100 billion dollars of tariffs and in a
second term i'll say this for the record
and i've talked many times with the
president about this we would have
completely raised tariffs on everything
to 100 and began to do what i believe
has to be done which is decouple from
communist china because every time china
makes another dollar
off
the united states or europe or whatever
um it it's able to fuel both its
military machine but also the the war
china is conducting like through the
so-called belt and road initiative i
don't know if you guys have
about that of course yeah it's it's uh
so it's basically the colonization of
africa latin america
kazakhstan and everything like that i
mean they've they've got a strategy and
the advantage they have over us
as a democracy is that um
we change governments
and officials every every four years
right and these guys that i would uh see
you i sat uh you know saka the g20
across from xi jinping and his married
band of apparatchiks same thing in
buenos aires uh many times i went to
beijing
these my point here is that these guys
across the table had been there for
years and they will be there for years
and i'll be gone and and instead now in
biden land they've got a bunch of uh
uh appeasers and people who here's the
way they do this tim it's like
there's money pots and honey pots okay
the honey pot is eric swalwell in
california right sleeping his way up and
down the coast with the chinese spies
i joked he had like stds like spy
transmitted diseases right that's that's
the honey pot right but the money parts
are much more insidious because what
china will do
with government officials is like
they'll give them like trips to beijing
or they'll put them in the think tank
they'll give them grants at universities
and these people become beholden to
uh the chinese and then they wind up
like jake sullivan as the national
security advisor right i mean this is
crazy stuff well there's well those well
he'll just do business dealings with
biden's sons and and i agree with your
point when it comes to decoupling
especially from china's pharma industry
which the united states is heavily
reliant on but i think previously what
you were describing was globalization
instead of libertarianism because when
we look at what china's doing they're
they're they're treating china like a
conduit for a multinational corporate
takeover of the world and people are
using china as a slave factory to
produce the goods but this was all
started under henry kissinger who
literally took manufacturing jobs from
the united states
industrialized and then took all the
jobs to china and now china now has
taken a lot of workforce a lot of
economic opportunities from the american
people and obviously if someone steals
from you that's not libertarianism there
should be consequences and you should
have a right to contract with who you
want to contract with and we shouldn't
be contracting with people who are
stealing from us so that libertarian
kind of idea still holds strong to me
but because of the multinational
corporations having so much power and
influence buying out the us government
we don't have libertarianism we don't
even have capitalism we have socialism
for the super rich which is orchestrated
by elites like kissinger
i take a really good short but nice shot
at henry yes he's he's he's he's you
know the dumbest one of the dumb smart
guys you meet along the way who's made
millions and millions and millions of
dollars from that the funny thing about
these corporations though the funny
thing about these corporations in
general electric is the poster child for
this all of these american corporations
who thought they could go over to china
offshore uh all the jobs and things like
that wound up getting destroyed over
there they got stripped of their
technology and they wound up having
competitors over there who were chinese
and then if you look like ge it's like
it hit its peak it was at its apex
then the moment it started to go over to
china that was the end of that
corporation now i again i'm old enough
to remember when ge was the most
important and powerful corporation in
the world today it's like
china just took that thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8pm don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel and if you want more unfiltered
and uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you